What kind of company is LogicBlox,
what sorts of things they sell?
>> So LogicBlox's primary product
is what we call a smart database.
It's an active cloud
database that has much
of the business logic that one would
normally need to write in a traditional
imperative language running on separate
machines down in the database.
So that when data
are added to the database,
these business rules kick in and
update views automatically.
It specializes in doing really
large-scale analytics and
applications that are kind of a hybrid
between transactional and analytic, and
that's really our sweet spot.
>> And
what sort of customers do you have and
the kinds of products that they need?
>> Yeah, so most of our customers that
are longer-term customers have been
customers in the retail domain,
that need to do analysis to decide how
many products they should order for a
given promotion, or forecast demand for
a given set of products at their stores,
or do financial planning.
These tend to be really large,
often multi-terabyte
applications that have years and
years of sales history that we use
to try to do a good job of forecasting
or predicting how products will move.
And we use our smart database
to analyze that and roll up and
roll down those data very efficiently.
>> So the terabytes is not
the size of the source code but
it's the amount of data that
they have to deal with.
>> That's correct.
Yeah,
the amount of source code
is meant to be very small.
The idea is that you want to declare
your business rules as concisely and
compactly and
as close to the way you'd want to
just say them in English is you can.
And then we install those
business rules into our database,
which then we load with
the terabytes of data.
>> And you mentioned in the cloud,
is this what they call softwares and
service?
>> It is, yes, so all of our
applications are sold as a service.
So our forecaster, which I think we're
going to talk about in a little while.
In particular, our forecast manager,
is a service that
big retail customers will pay
us a monthly fee to access.
Part of our model is that they
can at any time choose to.
They don't have to install
a lot of special hardware and
have IT expertise in house,
they can just subscribe to our service.
They access it through
standard web browsers.
They can turn it off and
on as they desire.
If they decide that they don't like
it anymore, they can just quit.
And so it's really nice for customers.
Part of our business proposition
is that we can quickly get into,
give access to a customer and
let them see the benefits.
They don't have to make a lot of upfront
commitment to use our technology and
they can decide to leave anytime.
>> So would you call this
a real time application?
>> I'm not sure I'd call
it a real time application.
It is an interactive application in
the sense that there will be users who
will be executing queries and
analyzing data
in what they would consider to be real
time so they need fast response time.
It's an interactive system.
It doesn't have hard
real time deadlines,
the way we normally think about
real time stuff being developed.
>> And how does the customer's data,
their sales data or
their product data get to you?
>> Yeah,
it's actually a little bit complicated.
So, customers tend to keep their data in
database systems that they've had for
50 years and
have their own special format and
they're very difficult
to integrate with.
What we tend to do is get them to export
the data that they need to send to us
and usually in just big CSV files or
some kind of delimited tabular file.
And they'll send us these
files at various times.
We have servers that will receive the
files and put them off to Amazon's S3
storage, it's a nice, very scalable,
very reliable storage system that we
use to keep the incoming data and from
that we load them into our databases.
>> But,
this data might be periodically updated.
>> That's correct.
>> Okay.
>> Often, on a daily basis, and
sometimes, for some customers,
even more frequent than that.